my name is mark good nur I'm here today
to talk to you about c++ in containers
I'm a program manager on the C++ team at
Microsoft our team works on the support
for C++ in both visual studio and Visual
Studio code so I work across both of
those those products are C++ extension
and Visual Studio our team is also
responsible for the Microsoft C++
compiler
I don't really have anything to say
about that today this talk is about
containers I'm not really showing
windows containers windows containers
are thing but I'm not really talking
about them much today and that's not
really my space on the C++ team at
Microsoft I spend more of my time on IOT
sort of stuff I've worked on our Linux
support and Visual Studio and things
like that I also work on an IOT project
at Microsoft called address fear which
is they secure an attempt to bring
security into the IOT space but that's
this talks not about that either
so containers if you're here to see a
talk about containers and C++ I presume
you probably have some baseline level of
what a container is but we can go ahead
and do a little bit of level setting
here so containers are very popular
these days because they're more
efficient than a VM they have a lot of
characteristics like a VM and that
they're self-contained but they're not
abstracted away from the host machine
via something like a hypervisor a
virtual machine thinks it is on a
machine a container knows that it's
right well container runs on a container
engine that provides a runtime
environment for the containers but it
actually does share resources with the
host operating system such as the kernel
but they do have some great
characteristics as opposed to virtual
machines in terms of things like that
they have lower disk cost so they're a
lot more efficient they also
self-contained dependencies so
containers the application in the
dependencies are actually isolated from
the host environment and this is all
described in a simple text file docker
file which makes it really great to be
able to run these anywhere now I
mentioned docker file docker is very
heavily associated with containers but
docker is just another runtime for
containers there's other runtimes out
there so
that's where docker kind of comes into
this picture and then there's isolation
the containers themselves are isolated
from the host so they don't have direct
access to the hosts resources so you
can't break out from a container and
manipulate the host environment for
example and the containers themselves
are actually isolated from each other
you have to expose services from a
container so that another container can
call it or anything else can call it but
what does this have to do with C++ why
C++ in containers I was talking with
some other folks and I guess I've been
looking at containers for a while just
kind of from the perspective of well I
work at Microsoft I work on the C++ team
we have a cloud containers are one way
that you can drive compute on a cloud so
it's interesting and C++ has a lot of
stuff to do with compute so why aren't
people talking about running C++ in
containers what are people doing instead
and a lot of people are talking about
rust and golang and these sort of things
but why'd are they talking about those
sort of things they're talking about
those sort of things because they have
characteristics like size that they can
be very optimized from a size
perspective from a binary perspective
well C++ can give you this too right you
can get very optimized binaries with C++
from performance perspective those
languages have similar characteristics
to C++ in terms of performance but why
can't you just use C++ in this
environment then and then finally scale
so if C++ is so great for performance
and containers are really great for
running in a cloud environment and being
able to scale them up you know as long
as you've got a good credit card why
aren't people talking about using C++
within this context you know what can we
do what are people talking about with
C++ in containers instead well build
containers build containers are
something that you definitely see
happening in the C++ community because
what C++ developer would not want a
single text file that you can check into
your repository that describes a
reproducible build environment all you
have to do is check that docker file
into github and anybody on your team can
clone it down and have this in the exact
same container image running locally and
the same build environment which is
pretty great and then you can also use
that in your CI CD system of course
and this is clean from the host machine
so it doesn't matter what the other
people on your team have installed from
a perspective of libraries or from a
perspective of compilers and those sort
of things because the docker file
actually describes the environment that
the container actually is right so it's
it's going to be the same and that even
actually works cross-platform I happen
to be using Windows for my host machine
here but somebody else could be doing
the same thing on Linux or Mac right so
that's pretty great so we will take a
quick look here at a build container and
so let's see so just gonna fire up PS
code this is just a simple little hello
world app it's just gonna print out
hello no big deal but in vs code I have
a docker extension installed and this
docker extension actually has the
capability to add docker files to your
work plate workspace is a quick way to
get started and we've actually got one
for C++ there so this is just gonna this
is an example of what a docker file
looks like
and so there's any people here are using
docker today okay so most of you so this
is probably a repeat for most of you so
this is a simple docker file at the top
there it says from GCC latest and GCC
what that means is it's going to pull
down a image GCC as the base image for
the container that image is going to
come from docker hub which is a
container registry it's an open and
public container registry the docker
maintains it's very common this is what
you'll see in most tutorials but there
are other container registries that are
run by different cloud vendors or other
people you can run a private container
registry so there's it's just a very
common one to use but this particular
docker image is maintained by GCC
themselves which is pretty great if you
want to actually be able to try out
specific versions of GCC then you can
get them directly from the source right
or you can track latest without having
to worry about building GCC from source
so the next thing that happens here is
it's going to copy in my directory
that's what the copy dot means it's
going to copy and everything in my
directory into the container at that
location of user source my app and then
the one thing it's not going to bring in
and this is important is anything that's
in this
ignore so you can specify files that you
don't want to pull into the container
image may be things like locally built
binaries or objects you don't want in
there because you want it produced in
the container and so here it's setting
in a working directory it's just gonna
run GCC directly on this because this is
like kind of a little toy example of how
to do this and then it's just going to
run the application and so in order to
do this we'll just say docker build dash
T says give the label to my target now
wait I'm just going to do this right
quick because I'm forgetting my name and
so I want to do dr. bill basic demo up
in DC and then the dot just means in
this directory so it's gonna pick up the
docker file from this directory and of
course I type it yeah awesome nothing
like too much talk too much coffee
before this right you said - oh yeah yes
and so that ran very fast because I've
already built this image before which is
why I was looking at that to make sure
that I was using the same name because
otherwise it would run through all the
compilation steps again and so if we
take another quick look at that docker
image LS and I can say GCC you can see
that the GCC image is about a gigabyte
in terms of what it pulls down but these
steps here are important because the
docker file actually has a strategy in
terms of how it builds up the local
image that's very optimized so that if
you change things in your docker file
you can invalidate the previous layers
when you're building but so there we go
and so if we want to run this we say
docker run
and it just says hello so that's great
so it ran now the other thing we can do
in terms of you know is a build system
you want to get your binaries out of
there right and so you can say docker
copy oh wait first we need to see our
container which isn't there because
right now that container is not running
it ran and exited so it's not still
running and so when you say - hey you
can get all of your containers over
there
it gives funny little random names to
your containers and then we can say
Dockers and copy give my container name
and then I can say they shall pop that
up a little bit higher on the screen oh
I see what I did so now you can see that
over here in my directory the my app
showed up but this isn't going to run in
PowerShell because that's a linux image
because I'm using a Linux image for the
container so I can quickly switch over
to WSL and fire up a new shell here and
now I've got a Linux environment on
Windows where I can actually run my app
and I've still got so now that that
application was able to be ported copied
out of the docker image and run in
another Linux environment and now I'm
going to set my default back to
PowerShell because I need it for the
rest of my demos so that's kind of a
quick demo just kind of you know what a
basic you know just getting started what
does the docker file look like you know
and what does it build in there look
like in this case we're running GCC
directly but you could run make you
could run a script you could run CMake
or anything else you need and the next
example will be a bit more involved than
that and so you know that's pretty great
because now I've got something that runs
on my machine and so with docker now I
can run on your machine too so this is
just a little meme I found online it's
pretty great but I mean this is really
kind of what Dockers about because it's
self packaging everything together so
that it's all together and you don't
have to bootstrap every single time but
so if we want to talk a little bit more
about like you know what does this look
like in a more real-world application we
can start talking a little bit about
micro services and what this sort of
stuff looks like and so in a micro
service you want to start with you want
to kind of
break things down into the smallest
units of logical work so that ever so
the system can be distributed and one of
the things that that gives you is
resiliency so that one now you have to
design your system this way of course
but when you design your system this way
if one part of the system goes down it
doesn't bring down everything else
because it's not monolithic and one of
the other cool things when you're using
containers is you can have different
host environments so you can have maybe
different base Linux images and you can
also have different dependencies so you
can use incompatible libraries for
example in different containers and so
that gives you a lot of flexibility in
terms of what you can actually use and
then finally you can start doing things
like scaling up units independently as
you need to because if one container is
getting hit because that service has
higher compute resource needs then you
can scale that container up independent
of the others to kind of optimize what
you need to do and then this one I think
is really interesting for C++ you can
start externalizing concerns to where
they're best handled like picking an
HTTP library maybe but what this means
is more practically is for things like
HTTP you can use something like a proxy
server like Ingenix they can actually
handle protocol transitions so that it
can be set up and configured for HTTP
with all of your certificates and
everything that's actually managed by
your IT staff and the deployments but
then it can actually bridge back to http
to run in the local container network
that's not exposed externally and then
you don't have to actually configure all
of the HTTP stuff you know from a
perspective of what you're having to do
in the applications that you're exposing
the services with so that's pretty great
and then finally there's this thing
called multistage builds that's really
great because it used to be that you had
to have different docker files for
different containers and so in order to
specify a runtime container that might
be different than your build container
you would have to actually set up two
different docker files maybe scripts to
manage this but now you can actually in
one file specify all of the stages of
your build container and then use those
resources and copy them into an output
another container that's actually your
runtime and I'll show that in just a
second and so if we want to start
talking about like what sort of
application could we look at to
look at these concepts I've got this
application that will find a face in AC
and it's exposed in a C++ web service
and so basically what we're gonna do is
set up a proxy server that will expose
our services to the X out side so that
the requests can come in from outside of
the container Network and then it can
proxy those requests back into our
node.js web app and this web app then
can call our C++ service that's using
OpenCV to find a face in a picture
that's submitted to it and circle that
face and so a user can come in they can
give their picture and it'll go to the
C++ sir OpenCV service and then the user
can come back and request to get that
image back from the service and the
service will return an image with the
faces circled and so let's take a look
at that so open vs code again oops oh
wait uh no that was right sorry I have
some weird directory structures so this
is an example is this big enough
actually I just forgot to ask on the
first time I open vs code it okay I've
got a thumbs up from the back so this is
another docker file this one is going to
describe two containers so the first one
the first thing you'll see is that the
from statement is labeled as billed so
now I can refer to this container within
the docker file in later steps and
access resources from this container and
later in later steps in producing the
docker file and so this one is actually
from another image called Alpine and
Alpine is pretty cool so if we go
docker image LS a you can see that the
the Alpine image is only six megabytes
so that's pretty great if you're trying
to manage your resources in terms of
what you're deploying especially if
you're deploying at scale this is a
great little container image to use
because it's so efficient now in this
one in order to build I'm pulling in all
of my updates I'm pulling in a whole
bunch of build build utilities and then
I'm doing a whole bunch of stuff here
that's not really too relevant but it's
probably the sort of thing you would see
in a in a real-world docker file where
you're pulling in a whole bunch of
assets that you need in order to build
in this particular case I'm using VC
package which is a library manager for
C++ libraries it doesn't support Alpine
so one of the guys on my team who works
on VC package hacked up some stuff so
that we could try using it with Alpine
and that's all of what that stuff is
doing but I don't want to talk about
that because I don't want you to have to
go out and try and use that will support
Alpine eventually someday but so then
what winds up happening down here at the
bottom is we run VC package we build all
of our libraries that this application
needs we set our working directory and
then this one actually uses C make we're
passing in a tool chain file and a bunch
of other stuff and finally making our
application and so for this I can say
build and I can actually say build the
target and I want to build that image
that's the build image from there and I
want to tag it as mine faces build you
don't have to do this it if you build
the runtime image it will actually build
all of this it'll just flow right
through and build the whole thing and
just create an intermediate container
but I like my containers labeled and so
this one had better run fast because oh
wow thank you
double dash for target and so that ran
really fast this because it's actually
been built before
none of the and so that's the thing I
was talking about before was that
different layers of an image can become
invalidated by subsequent layers so if I
did something like run this and then I
later ran another apk update afterwards
it could invalidate all of the previous
layers and everything would have to be
run again and so you want to be
cognizant when you're building your
layers and the each statement in here
can produce a different image layer and
so you need to be careful about that but
at any rate so now we've got that one
and now if I want to re if I want to run
or build the runtime environment I can
say next let me pop this up bigger
and then now I don't have to specify a
target because it's going to run all the
way through and to that last runtime
target that I had specified and the
initial build of that initial build
container when I move this across
machines and build that because of the
number of library because I'm using an
HTTP library that has boost dependencies
the initial run of that build container
takes about a few hours at least and so
now what we can see actually let's clear
this and now we can see oops so these
are the container images that I have for
this application and you can see that
the build container is actually about
six gigabytes but the runtime container
is only about 50 megabytes and so that's
that's great savings in terms of you
know the cost of disks that you're gonna
have you know especially if you're
running in a cloud environment and you
can see there's also the web site which
is a node.js app that's at about 140
Meg's
so the c++ is clocking in pretty good
here and this is actually more efficient
than some other stuff that you could use
as well now to run all of these services
together in this particular example I'm
going to use docker compose which is
something that just comes with docker
desktop you specify this docker compose
yamo file and so what this is doing is
it's actually specifying different
services that are using these images
that are that are output here that you
can see and some I'm starting the
service for the web app I'm starting a
service for the C++ service and I'm
starting another service for what I'm
calling the website which is actually in
genex and so I didn't build a separate
Ingenix image that's actually just the
public name for the image for Ingenix
and so when I run this docker compose
file for the first time it's actually
gonna look out to docker hub and it's
gonna pull Ingenix down and install that
image locally on my machine and then use
that for running the service the other
ones that are specified are not in a
public image repository anyway it's just
finding them from my local images a lot
of tutorials will tell you to do things
like build your image locally and then
push it to docker hub you don't actually
need to do that if you
build your image locally you can
reference that name locally you don't
need to push it up in order to find it
and so finally you can see that the all
of these are using this network app
network and so this app network is a
simple bridge network that you specify
here and so now all of these containers
can see each other and these containers
can see each other by the name that is
specified here for each service and then
only one of the services has ports that
are exposed so the Ingenix one has is
exposed on port 8080 that's mapping
internally to 80 and we have this
Ingenix configuration here that is
actually a standard kind of reverse
proxy and so what this is saying is that
for the route location redirect to the
web app that's running on port 3000 on
the internal network and then for if
it's under slash files which is where
the C++ service is expecting to find
things then it's on port 4000 and so I
also want to show you one quick thing
about the web app because this was very
tricky or at least it was tricky for me
to grok understanding this what you'll
see here is that within this web app
there's this request here that's
actually going to the internal network
name so because this is running inside
the container it's using the name of the
service that's the internal service name
and so that's where the request is
happening this request is not happening
outside of the container network but
there's this other file here which is
this image file which is actually going
to display our return image and here I'm
just using the image tag to get the
image back and there I'm specifying
localhost 8080 slash files to hit the
C++ web service to get that image back
and that's because that request is
actually happening in the web browser
it's not happening in the container on
the internal container network it's
happening external and so it's it's
almost embarrassing how long it took me
to figure this out and debug this but it
is it is the sort of thing that you can
trip up on but let's go back to the
other one and so we've got our container
images now so now how do I actually use
this it's pretty simple so I say docker
compose
shows up and - D means to attach so that
it won't lock my terminal here so yeah
so all of my services are up now so I
should be able to hit that and so now we
can go to localhost 8080 you can see
that my web development skills were
honed in the age when HTML did not have
a version number and from here we can
actually choose a file there's a lot of
things in this world that make me feel
old these days I'm not sure if this
picture of Ken Thompson and Dennis
Ritchie taking in the year that I was
born makes me feel old or young but it
will pick that picture and then will
upload it to our service and there you
can see it's actually so it's actually
taking that service or that picture it's
posted it to the C++ service and then
it's used OpenCV to circle their faces
and save the file and now we've could
use to get requests to return it back
and now if I want to bring this down I
can just say docker compose down and
then that's going to take everything
back down again so those containers will
all stop and my resources will be
cleaned up
so the pretty easy way to try working
with multiple containers with services
working with each other
so let's come back
all right so what did we see so we saw a
multi-stage build container for a C++
web service so just a couple of simple
commands there in order to use that and
then we saw a hell we defined the
related services in a docker compose
diamo file and then we configured the
Ingenix proxy server settings and then
we were mindful of you know how we
needed to make whether the network calls
were being made on the internal
container network or if the calls were
being made from the external of the
container network and then a couple
simple commands to bring that up and
down but so this is this is all cool and
everything but you know I mean I did say
that this was about the cloud right and
so so what about it what does it mean to
use containers in the cloud well you
know really when you're talking about
using containers in the cloud you're
going up there for scalability purposes
maybe to use a lot of compute so you're
gonna have a bunch of containers running
right now I could sit here and start
showing you how to do this in Azure or
maybe I could be contrary and show you
how to use a AWS or Google but I really
wanted to show you how to use this in
kind of a vendor-neutral way because
there's something that all of the
vendors are actually using today to
supply these services of how you
actually manage containers at scale
because that's really what the cloud is
about it's about scale and so how do you
manage these containers at scale and
what you need to manage containers at
scale is an orchestration service and so
today what orchestration really means in
the cloud world is kubernetes if you go
look at the documentation for working
with containers and most of the
different cloud vendors it's usually a
thin layer on top of kubernetes or it's
just straight kubernetes so kubernetes
is really what you want in order to
manage a bunch of containers so what is
kubernetes how many of you are using
kubernetes okay that significantly fewer
than the number of people using
containers which isn't surprising
so kubernetes starts with kind of
defining two clusters so that's kind of
the core root object level of kubernetes
that you're interacting with this
cluster and a cluster contains one or
more nodes a node you can think of as a
machine within the cluster that could be
a physical machine it could be a virtual
machine
and kubernetes can manage more than just
containers it's a complete orchestration
service that manages all sorts of
resources but we're not going to look at
anything other than containers within a
cluster you have a pod and so this is
the object that you actually manage you
know what what you're doing with the
different containers in here in a pod
can contain one or more containers and
the interesting thing about a pod is
compared to just a container is that a
pod the containers in a pod all have
access to the same resources and the
kubernetes environment can actually
manage pods across multiple nodes
because the whole thing about this is
scale right so you want your cluster to
grow bigger and you want to have
multiple nodes and you want to be able
to manage all of these resources and
when something goes wrong or when your
IT staff needs to scale something up or
down they need to be they need to be
free to move these containers maybe to a
different geo region maybe they need to
scale it up or down and the pods give
them the ability to move those
containers across different nodes in the
network without impacting what's
actually running in the containers but
that doesn't really tell you much about
how you're going to work with this does
it so when you're working with
kubernetes the thing you're probably
going to be working with is a deployment
and a deployment is going to describe a
pod and different resources that you're
using within that pod and then in order
to have these things work across
different pods different containers
you're going to need to expose an
application that's running there as a
service so that other things within that
cluster can reference that and use the
resources from it and then there's this
other concept of a job a job you can
think of as a simple cron job you can
have scheduled jobs that will describe a
pod and will spin up a pod and do some
tasks from from start to completion jobs
actually support parallelism depending
on how you configure things whether or
not the application you want to run can
support parallelism of course this
parallelism and how you package
applications to move them across
different kubernetes environments is a
much bigger topic so I don't have very
much to say about that jobs are not
really what you would use for that sort
of thing but they're simple enough for
us to describe in a simple kind of demo
app present
like this where we can actually show
some simple parallelism but just know
that parallelism in general is a big
concept or a deep topic area within this
space jobs aren't suitable for things
like scientific computing so if you've
got a scientific computing app that you
want to try and throw this sort of
technology that you're want to go you're
going to want to look at something other
than jobs and then finally we have
persistent volume claims these are a way
that you can specify storage or memory
that different pods can access and it
can have a lifetime beyond the lifetime
of the pod and now when I look at
something like this you know what am I
going to show you how can I build a demo
app that would actually use all of these
concepts and you know I started thinking
about that and you know what would be
something interesting to scale up I mean
I could scale up that that face web
service but it's already kind of
performant it's not really that
interesting and I also kind of wanted to
do something without network access
because I think a lot of C++ stuff you
might want to run in a cloud you know to
process a whole bunch of files or
something maybe maybe a legacy app maybe
you've got a legacy app that you want to
try and move up so maybe if that legacy
app took like a file input and instead
of having a single file maybe we could
parallelize it by you know running that
same app but you know what the queue of
files for it to process and so I was
thinking about this and I'm not sure I
didn't test this so we'll see if this
works but I was thinking about what's
the react this could be and I started
thinking about the Simpsons and I
started thinking about my favorite
episode of The Simpsons which is space
Homer so we'll see if this actually if
the audio works here
[Music]
you fool now we may never know if ants
can be trained to sort tiny screws in
space that was a little quiet but the
punchline there was we'll never know if
ants can be trained to sort Chinese
screws in space and so you know but can
ants sort tiny screws in space if he
didn't have Homer there and he hadn't
ruined their experiment you know how
would you how would you know how would
you know if ants can count tiny screws
in space you know maybe you want to
count them by the different ant type you
know this this shows from the 90s so you
know it's probably CSV data right they
got it they've got to be tracking this
in CSV it's probably batch processing of
data from yesterday because it's got to
get back from space right and we didn't
have the sort of modems we have today
although I honestly don't know what kind
of modems we have for space but in any
rate C++ was cool in the 90s right still
is yeah different ways but back then it
was rocket scientists using C++ so
that's pretty great but it's many years
right what if this experiments still
running what if they got more ants up
there they got more sensors more data we
want to get that app off and off of an
old system that's being retired you know
we need to migrate it somewhere because
that is a very big topic for containers
actually a lot of people use containers
to lift an application off of old
hardware and move it into another
environment just to preserve that
application in an environment that
matches the original so that's kind of a
important topic for this sort of stuff
but when we do this could we also scale
it could we make it work better so let's
let's think about that so how could we
do this so with what I've explained so
far so I'll set up a persistent volume
claim that the apps can share just put
all of the data in and I'm going to set
up a deployment that has a Redis server
with a queue for ant files and then I'm
going to expose it as a service so that
different containers can actually access
this and so first I'm going to run a job
that's got a little C++ application and
it's gonna that jobs can create a pod
that is mapped in that persistent volume
flame is a slash data at the gray box
ant space data is a little C++ app
that's going to generate a whole bunch
of files CSV files for my simulated ant
space data because
they don't have a Space Shuttle with
ants on it
and then I have a little Python script
that's just gonna scroll through all of
the data that's been generated and
populate the Redditt queue with a bunch
of key value pairs of the file names so
that I can then use those file that I
can then scale this up and the way I'm
going to do that is I have another job
that I'm going to run after that first
job is done and so I'm mapping in the
data directory again so I've got access
to the date of the previous pop
generated and then my little Python
script is going to read the cue from the
Redis server and it's just a queue of
the filenames and then it's going to
invoke my C++ app that just takes the
filename as the input and then it's
going to generate a little report about
how many screws were counted by which
kind of ants and so now we can go ahead
and pop out and take a look at that so
the first thing we want to do is look at
our kubernetes assets and here what we
have this is much too big there we go
alright so this is a description of a
deployment so we've got a little bit of
metadata that gets specified in this
case since I'm running locally on my
machine I'm not specifying any sort of
replication one one instance of this is
fine and then you can see down here for
the container it's using the image name
Redis again this is a the name from
docker hub I didn't build this locally
here but when I ran this the first time
it reached out to docker hub and pulled
that Redis image down so that I could
use it locally and then then for the
environment it has some things that gets
set for Redis and there's also the
command for the container that gets run
which is write a server to start that up
I've got another little yamo file here
that specifies I want to expose a
service for that Redis server and then I
have another little demo file that just
says some details about the persistent
volume claim that pods can later use and
so in order to deploy this oh and
actually before I show you this so this
is docker desktop this is available
cross-platform it's great for you know
just doing
local development but the one thing I
want to show you docker desktop actually
supports kubernetes it's not on by
default but if you want to try playing
with kubernetes if you start looking at
guides about kubernetes you're gonna
find all sorts of stuff about how we run
cuban eddies with things called mini
cube and all sorts of other stuff that's
really hard to configure and is
distributed in ways that she won't get
updates just installed docker the docker
desktop and just enable kubernetes here
you'll get Cube control which is the
command-line utility you need and
everything will just be set up and you
can get going
just ignore all of these guides with
their complex multi-page documentation
about how to get started with kubernetes
just do this and then you can follow the
rest of the guide once they start
talking about cube control the
command-line utility you can just skip
until they get to that and this will
work it took me too long to figure that
out
but so what I want to do is use cube
control which is a primary CLI interface
for kubernetes and I'm just going to say
apply and apply apply - eff or file but
it's going to apply all of the files in
this directory so with that I have
actually deployed all of these things
that were specified in the ammo files
that just showed you and so then I can
say cube controller cluster info just to
kind of come back to the concepts I was
showing on the slide before so this is
information about the cluster I'm using
so it's running here on my machine and
we can see oops there's kind of a
standard syntax for this so I can say
cube control get nodes and so I only
have one node which is my local docker
desktop here and then I can say cube
control get deployments and we can see
the Redis deployment that I just created
and if I say cube control get pods we
can see the pods that that created so
we've got a pot up and running now
docker is the runtime environment for
the containers so if I want to see the
containers I can actually say docker
container LS and now you can see I
actually have a container running there
that Redis spun up now red I'm sorry
that the kubernetes spun up now the
interesting thing is if I were to come
in here and muck with this with
shocker and if I were to say stop that
container kubernetes actually knows
what's going on in its environment and
kubernetes would say no no no no I've
got a deployment that's running and it's
supposed to be running in a container
for Redis and so if I stopped it outside
of that environment without getting rid
of my deployment first kubernetes will
just spin the container back up again or
spin another container back up again yes
I did create a person a persistent
volume self way cute control get PBC oh
I'm sorry I didn't create a persistent
volume I decided to use a persistent
volume claim so yeah I just found that
easier to do with the containers or with
the with the pods I created later and so
that's our that's our basic environment
here so now we've got all of the stuff
that was on the left side of the slide
yes left side of the slide up and
running and so now I can say bring up
another instance of vs code and we can
look at generating our space data and so
for this one now I have an a job that's
specified in this job again here it's
using a local image so if I say docker
image LS you can see I've already I've
already generated I've already built
this container image and so it's
actually going to find the local the
local container here again like this
image name a lot of the guides will tell
you that you need to publish your image
publicly to docker hub in order to use
it it's not true you can put you can
just build your image locally and refer
to the local name right there and it'll
work now the other thing I'm doing here
is I'm setting some environment
variables in the container for the
number of files I want to generate how
many lines how many machs lines and then
here's the volume mount so now I'm just
using the persistent volume claim and
then I'm mounting it into the slash data
path here and then for the docker file
itself
I've got another little multistage build
container here I'm using a version of
Alpine that's all from Python that
already has Python set up for me which
gives me a little bit less work I need
to do
now in my daugher ignore this
yeah so in my daugher ignore i made sure
to put the binary name that I'm
generating because in my local testing I
and I I forgot to put my binary name in
the docker ignore file when I was doing
this initially and I was copying my
binary into the container image and it
made it in part on another machine and I
did a lot of debugging to figure that
out only to realize that I was copying a
binary into the container and so it
wasn't it so that was getting just
copied back out into another container
and of course I'm not running alpine
locally so of course it wasn't working
but so the docker file it's pretty basic
and then we're copying from the build
output we're copying the the C++ app and
the little Python script all the Python
script does as I mentioned the Python
script just reads the environment
variables to see how many lines it needs
to generate and output that and then it
invokes the C++ app with those there's
not really too much interesting in the
C++ app it's just generating it's just
generating a whole bunch of files based
on the numbers I gave it with some
random data based on those numbers and
then once it's done with that it comes
down here and it actually connects to
the Redis queue and then it's just loops
over the directory to push the generated
file names into the Redis queue and of
course you could do that from C++ but it
didn't seem particularly performance
related so Python is good glue code so
that's how I decided to do that and so
in order to apply this we can then again
do Cube control apply dash F and instead
of doing the entire directory I can
actually just say which file name I want
to use so that's going to spin that out
and then we can say who control get jobs
and so we can see that our job is
running here and then I can say Cube
control get pods and now we can see that
we actually have a pod running for
and space data and we can say you can
actually get the output of what's
running in a pod by saying cube control
logs oops and the right pod name I can
hear my computer's fan running so now
the other thing that's interesting here
so this is the log is still in process
because the files are still being
generated but if I say cube control get
pods again one thing that's kind of
interesting here that's useful to know
so you can copy this Redis cue name and
you can actually say cube control exec
internet IT interactive and then my pod
name and I can say bash and so now I'm
actually in the pod and I can actually
start interacting with things that are
running there locally and see what's
going on and I can say write a CLI and I
can connect to the server that we're
running and now I can say take a look at
what's in that queue and so my queue
name is ant files and so I can say start
at the beginning and end when it's done
and so now I can see like that Redis
queue just has the list of the file
names
that's all that's in that Redis queue is
and I can tell because it's 20 that
that's the number that I set so I'm
pretty sure I'm done and so now if we
look back at the pods again and we can
see that indeed the ants base data has
finished generating now and now what's
cool even though that has finished I can
actually still look at the logs for it
and so now you can see the log file is
different you can see that I got to the
end of my work queue and it's exited so
that's pretty great and then so finally
now we want to proud now we want to do
all of our work so you can say let's
look at the screw counter and for this
one this is just another little job
definition and so for this one you can
notice here on parallelism I've set it
to two so now I'm going to spin up two
pods so I can actually scale this up I
could say ten if I wanted to but this is
pretty great because now I've got now I
can take that original application I can
scale it out I have my image here for
ant screw counter
that I built before and if we take a
look at that in the doctor or sila yeah
sure let's talk about that later so we
can say doctor image LS and I want to
look at this these containers or these
images I should say and so you can see
that here again the Brun containers a
little bit smaller than the billed
container but not not dramatically so in
this particular instance and then again
I'm mapping in the data path from that
persistent volume claim if I take a look
at the dockerfile one thing you'll
notice here I switched away from Alpine
at this point I'm using a debian variant
here is my build container and it wasn't
really the build container that was a
problem it was the runtime container
that was a problem and so you can see
here I'm setting locales in my C++ code
I was using function for format the cop
to format commas that use locale in
order to format the commas it turns out
that if you actually start looking into
it
Alpine isn't great with locales it's
really hard to configure locales on on
Alpine I found a lot of stuff about this
from web devs about their struggles with
locales and Alpine so this is one of the
great things you can throw your hands up
in the air and say alright well then
I'll just use a different host
environment and so I switch to Debi and
we're little cows were working and I was
back to the races you know and the thing
is another team member of mine said well
why don't you just stop using locales I
said well yeah I could but I liked that
function and I don't want to and it's
just a demo app but if if size were
really important to me then I could make
those sort of decisions to use a
different function in order to still use
Alpine if size was really important to
me but finally so we copied the output
from the from the build container into a
runtime container and then you can see
here we're spending up the entry point
for the container is the Python another
Python script this Python script
basically all it does prints out how
it's being used and then what it does is
it connects to the Redis Q so that's
what it's doing here
it's gonna it's connecting to the Redis
work queue and then what it's doing is
its looping over the work queue and it
grabs a item out of the work queue and
puts a lease on it so that another
worker won't grab that same item out of
the work queue and I picked 120 seconds
in playing with this that's about that
was max enough for what I'm doing here
and then while it's got that at least it
calls the sub process which is the ant
screw counter passing at it's filename
and down in here we can see where's my
main so all the main is doing is it's
taking that file name and then it's
opening that path with a C++ library
called CSV monkey I'll have a link in
there but there's actually a thing
called CSV game which looks at what are
the most performant programming
languages for CSV I'm sure you won't be
surprised that C++ is the winner but the
most performant library was that CSV
Monkey so that was why I picked that one
but it's a header only file and then
that's then it just runs through that
and then it just prints out a little it
just prints out a little report on which
ants counted the most screws and so in
order to run this we can come back over
here and we can say cube Patrol
apply and then we will I should
oops that was it Hockman where's my
funny man screw counter there we go so I
apply my yamo file that describes my job
so it created my job I can see with cube
control get jobs that there it's there
it's running well it looks like ones
already completed and I can say Q
control get pods and indeed I can see
there that this ran fast enough that
both of those pods have already
completed but I can grab one of these
and I can actually look at the output
from that and there's my logs now I
really wanted to print this on green and
white paper with punch holes on the side
but I really didn't want to take up an
entire bag
the printer that big so that's what
we've got for that and so coming back
here so with no Homer we've actually got
our ants have finally sorted screws and
we finally know how many they've sorted
and so looking at this in review
so we specified some basic kubernetes
resources in order to distribute our
work setting up reddest red a server for
in a persistent volume claim for
managing the files and both how we
wanted to divide the work up and then
generated cement files so just a little
C++ app to generate an arbitrary number
of files and a little python script that
just ran over the number of the
generated files to populate the work
queue and then it was spent all
specified in a kubernetes job that just
runs it run to completion and then
finally for counting the screws there
was another C++ app that took the CSV
file as input and then add a Python
script there's the entry point to the
containers that read from the work queue
and Redis and then invoke the C++ app
with the file that it had and then
finally that cuber Nettie's job just
spun up and ran in multiple ran multiple
pods in parallel so kind of wrapping up
what we saw I think that hopefully you
can see that C++ and containers have a
bunch of complementary characteristics
that these things can work well together
building in containers is valuable it's
easy to get started you see a lot of
this in the C++ community today of
people using build containers because
it's just such an obvious win in
multi-state once you move on to actually
running your app in a container
multistage builds can really help in
terms of keeping your build and your
runtime definitions in sync with each
other but I think the thing I want you
to take away from this is that C++ it
has a it has a place in containers
beyond just build environments it really
lets you externalize some of your
concerns to where they're best handled
particularly when you think about the
people we're going to have to keep the
system up and running over time that if
you can externalize concerns to where
the right people can manage those assets
and those resources the better
but that means that C++ can be used in
these modern cloud invited deployments
and kubernetes can be used with it to
paralyze your C++ workloads and so so
what now is you know kind of look to the
people here you know that you should go
out and learn and share how to deploy
C++ apps in a modern cloud environment
or just even in a base kubernetes
environment like this it's applicable to
any cloud and the reason why is go out
there and try and find information on
this and you're not going to find it
nobody's talking about this I know that
people are doing it because whenever I
talk about something like this whenever
I write a blog post about containers in
C++
I have enterprise customers contact me
asking me questions about what they're
doing and sharing stuff about what
they're doing people are doing this but
there's not a lot of public information
out there about it and I think that
there's a lot to be said for that we can
all do a lot more with C++ than just the
language itself we need to talk more
about how we use C++ in these modern
environments because we're just not
talking about it we seem to only talk
about spaceship operator and stuff but
you know deployment practices for these
apps they're just not well known and you
know but here's some questions that I've
got you know and that I've been trying
to work through myself as well that I
think that you know that all of y'all
could take a look at - because I think
the first blog post I wrote about
containers and C++ was about one year
ago and now I'm here talking about it so
I think that there's there's an appetite
for this sort of stuff but there's just
a lot more that can be done it's a very
deep topic area it's less about the
language it's more about how you can run
these apps in this sort of environment
and even for things like build I mean
what are the best practices for managing
build and running containers in a CI CD
system I see a lot of people doing it I
find you know I can find public repos of
C++ apps that have a CI CD system
specified I don't see any documentation
about how it was configured and set up
it must have been simple right
because otherwise they must not that
must be why they didn't describe it you
know but so with that
I'll get the slides posted I included
some references here to a bunch of stuff
that I used in terms of how to figure
out how to build all of these demos a
couple of the links down there at the
bottom are shameless plugs to some of my
own blog posts that MSNBC post in a
container that seems their windows
containers are a thing they are thing a
lot of people use windows containers for
lifting and shifting dotnet applications
to the cloud so that's a place where
they really have probably most but I
actually have talked to enterprise
customers who are trying to lift and
shift Windows C++ apps to the cloud as
well and I'll probably be writing some
more about that in the future that's my
github repo down there at the bottom I
don't have the source for all of this
postage yet because I needed to work on
my content and not keep monkey in with
my source code so I'm going to monkey
with my source code now that I'm done
and get that posted soon and you'll be
able to find it there I'll make sure the
slides are there as well and with that
I've also got a troubleshooting slide
here in terms of some tips and tricks
that I used in terms of debugging this
application as I was going through and
with that questions so the question is
kind of the the productivity impact of
trying to work with containers in a
complex app like this right I see
I see okay so there's a lot to unpack
there and I'm not sure I'm gonna be able
to echo all of that back to the mic for
the recording we'll try so you're
talking about some of the difficulties
in particular with embedded systems and
getting a build container set up with
the cross compiling tool chains and that
sort of stuff and it had an impact on
your development team in terms of
productivity there's probably a lot to
say about that I kind of intentionally
didn't talk about IOT in this
presentation although it's interesting
because within the broader C++ ecosystem
the people that I've seen adopt
containers more than anybody else
actually are the embedded in IOT folk
which is unusual because they seem to be
such laggards usually but in this space
for C++ they're actually much more ahead
of people and I'm surprised that you
actually had that level of difficulty
with containers and cross compilers was
this a recent project or an older one
okay legacy so legacy legacy embedded
projects I can believe yeah maybe
there's more to run into there I'm
actually seeing a lot of activity and
try and people trying to move cross
compiling tool chains into containers
and one of the reasons people are
interested in doing that is is
specifically because of the complexity
of setting up a cross compiling
environment to begin with and so if you
can successfully get it into a container
to build then you're one step ahead of
the game for getting new team members up
and running I think you mentioned
flashing and things like that and I
think that that's an area where more
work is needed because nomads even if
you can build in a container for a
embedded app you still need to flash in
debug on the device in order to actually
be productive and a lot of times those
tools are kind of maybe wrapped up in
the cross compiling tools themselves as
well and because you need to break out
to USB or serial doing that from the
container environment back to the host
can be difficult
I've heard of people doing it but I
don't really have any good documentation
or examples I've seen but I've heard
people talk about it it's something
we're looking at one of our teams
Microsoft is actually working on getting
cross-compiling toolchains for embedded
microcontrollers into containers
specifically to try and help with
acquisition and building and that sort
of stuff so I think that there's a place
for it
the interesting thing though as well is
that sometimes in edge computing
environments in IOT where you actually
have a larger machine that has maybe GPU
or a higher level of compute in those
scenarios we are seeing people actually
deploy containers as a runtime
environment and I think I think we're
doing it for azure IOT edge I believe
Amazon's Greengrass project has
something similar that they're doing I
think the hardest thing about those
environments is they're often very
similar to kubernetes deployments but
the concepts are documented differently
because in particularly different cloud
vendors but hopefully we see some
harmonization there so it's easier to
reason about
but in those in those instances a lot of
times people are trying to get to the
containers to deploy down there because
it lets them use higher-level languages
because they're also on a machine that
can run a container a microcontroller is
not going to run a container but you
know if you've got something that's got
a GPU you know or something bigger at
the edge then you can run containers
there now now for now it's great because
everything's self-contained right and
we've even seen things where we've got
examples of CI CD systems that are
producing the container runtime images
and actually pushing them all the way
down to the edge so it's it's an
exciting area it's too bad you had
difficult it may be it's a history of
like you've mentioned legacy yes yeah
right yeah it's yeah so it's it's a
question of scale so in a CIC the
comments I think is that for a CI CD
system there's a there's a an obvious
win from a scale perspective and a
manageability perspective of the build
system to move into a container but for
a local individual developer there may
not be as much of a gain I don't know I
mean I think that I think that there are
gains for using build containers locally
as well it does mean you need to think a
little bit differently but yeah I still
think there's a gain because it's much
easier to it
would be much easier to on ramp people
but then they'll have to deal with some
extra concepts of working with
containers but luckily that doesn't
require thinking about kubernetes and
all of the other stuff it should just be
install docker docker build and you
should it should be simple but it's not
always yeah any other questions
alright well thanks a lot
[Applause]